like me we both came out here to Los
Angeles writing time have you settled
into being an Angelina this place is
shitty you know I got you don't worry
only 90 percent of the crowd is from
here if you're a long time I like it but
it chips away at your soul in weird ways
your eyes how does it chip away at your
soul well there's no seasons alright so
and initially you think like well that's
great it's kind of nice all the time
you're like yeah but you don't feel time
going by right right so one day you just
wake up and you're like I've been here
12 years yeah I don't you remember why I
came out here I don't think it worked
out well what about okay did you over
after you're here for a little while you
said some oh yeah okay that's right
there there are seasons like once a year
you'll find yourself saying like well
there are ants and shits on fire must be
summer how is that not chipping away
your soul when you actually just
accommodate the idea like yep once a
year everything just burns here to
thousands of acres that's it that's LA
it's fire time and then like panicky
friends and relatives call from the East
Coast like are you all right and I'm
like what are you talking about no way
the fires I'm like oh that's not by me
I don't know where that is what's the
name of the town yeah oh yeah I don't
know that might be by me I'm not sure
yeah I think we're okay no it's so
massive here that whenever something in
the news happens and it's from Los
Angeles it could still be 60 miles away
from yeah well you would have no idea
well that's that's the other worst thing
is just like you know like I know we
weren't even gonna talk about this but I
cannot deal with this how it chips away
your soul like if I have to get up in
the morning and I know I got to travel 7
1/2 miles like I have to say to myself
well [ __ ] I better give myself an hour
for seven and a half mile like I gotta
go to that building over there I should
have left last night
how is that not ridiculous
you